foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar studying
protein polymerization with Mass
photometry
I am Morgan Sterling of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by refine to learn more visit
refine.com
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits after the webinar
we do encourage you to participate in
today's event by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd now like to welcome our speaker
Nicholas hunt postdoctoral research
associate Ludwig Maximilian University
of Munich Nicholas you may now begin
your presentation
yeah thanks for the kind introduction
um and I would like to thank refine at
this point for sponsoring this webinar
and um I would like to thank all of you
for your interest in my webinar I would
say let's jump right into it
you've all probably heard in one or the
other way about these proteins that I've
listed here they are all biopolymers
which are involved in many different
important cellular processes
for example up there you see actin and
microtubules which are an essential part
of the cytoskeleton and they are
basically involved in all the processes
where cell where cells need to change
their shape or move for example for
um yeah production of cell protrusions
or cell migration cell division and so
on
um and then there's another group of
common biopolymers which are called
amyloids
um they are actually not one type of
protein but many different ones and
amyloids are rather a structural state
of um proteins where proteins form
polymeric beta sheets and then from this
over time form three-dimensional
structures which are called fibrils and
they are important for a number of very
prominent disorders they usually usually
associated with the progression of the
disease the
um the examples that I've listed here
are for example important for
Alzheimer's Parkinson's Huntington's
disease diabetes and called celiakov's
disease
in order to understand the regulation of
all these processes it's of course
crucial to understand how these polymers
are formed and um how do you actually
study the Assembly of a bio-polymer well
you can start off by understanding what
your polymer looks like structurally for
example and for this you can employ high
resolution techniques such as x-ray
crystallography or cryo cryoelectron
microscopy and this way you can for
example obtain atomic structures of your
monomeric subunits as well as the um the
polym the polymerized state of your
protein but of course
um looking at only the structure will
not tell you much about how the
polymerization process is regulated and
how it actually functions dynamically
so um if you want to learn something
about the polymerization process
dynamically you will probably go to a
less resolution
technique uh usually a microscopy light
microscopy techniques are employed for
this very common is fluorescence
microscopy where you label the
individual some individual subunits of
your polymer with a fluorescent dye and
then you can watch individual polymers
grow and Shrink over time this is very
useful to get like basic kinetic
constants for the growth and shrinkage
out
as well as to understand how for example
Regulators influence this process
but for the regulation it's not only in
interesting or important to look at the
um the overall polymerization process
but it's also important to understand
how the polymerization process starts
and there it becomes a lot more
difficult to assess this uh this this
initial part of the assembly because we
cannot employ
so easily these Optical techniques
anymore and up until now it's actually
very it's actually common to explore
this process just with bulk techniques
and typically a bulk polymerization
assay
uses different kinds of bulk
signals such as fluorescence scattering
viscosity or biafringence measurements
to follow the um the accumulation of the
polymer over time and solution and this
polymeric this polymerization signal
um
can usually be subdivided into in three
different phases
the first one is called the nucleation
phase where the line stays mostly flat
this is where the polymerization is
usually started
then you go into the elongation phase
where the signal will rise much more
quickly this is where the major portion
of the polymers is formed and then later
on you enter a stationary phase where
polymer growth comes to an end and
enters more like a steady state where
growth and shrinkage is more or less in
equilibrium
um now from from these polymerization
curves especially if you do them at
different polymer concentrations
you can deduce somewhat
um rates for the initial steps as well
as
an overall polymerization rate
um but as you as you might guess since
this nucleation phase actually just
happens in this flat regime of the curve
there's not much information really
about the molecular pathway that
underlies this polymerization process uh
and and usually you have to come up with
a kinetic model and try to simulate your
bio-polymerization curves based on that
kinetic model and this is how we figure
out
um different molecular Pathways during
the nucleation process
for actin the first models have come up
in the
1960s and 70s and these nucleation
models have have been refined over over
the uh over the decades
up until
2001 where I think in well in my opinion
the most detailed model came out for for
actin polymer nucleation
um David sept and Andrew McCammon try to
simulate
all possible nucleation Pathways for
actin based on a Brownian Dynamic
simulation
and essentially how um what what they
did was as you can see on the left
the the actin polymer consists of a of
two helical strands the blue one and the
red one and each actin subunit can have
context to the neighboring longitudinal
subunits in the same strand as well as a
cross filament contact
with the subunits on the other strand
basically and uh and then they've
they've essentially simulated how stable
all the possible combinations of nuclei
were based on based on their Iranian
Dynamics
and figured out a major pathway in which
this nucleation process should happen
which is encircled with the dashed line
here
so um basically you can have two
different diamonds what's their
conclusion which are relevant
one is the longitudinal diamond and the
cross filament dimer and
and then
um and then they figured out uh growth
uh like Association and dissociation
rates as well as dissociation constants
for each of these steps and their major
conclusion was that the rate limiting
step is the formation of a dimer
and once the system has reached a
trimeric state afterwards all the
subsequent steps are more or less
working in the same way with the same
rate constants
and then when they use this model
um and scale their theoretical rate
constants to experimental we determined
ones and compare their
predicted by scattering curves with
experimental ones and found that their
model would explain it quite well
and they could even determine time
courses for for the individual different
nucleation species
over over time but unfortunately up
until now
um this theoretical model could not be
confirmed experimentally
and you you would ask yourself why is
why is that the case that of more than
20 years
um it was not possible to reproduce this
experimentally
well how would you measure this
essentially the simple task would be to
quantify all polymer species dynamically
using single molecule Imaging
well yeah um I mean who has ever tried
to to quantify this experimentally for
example with single molecule
fluorescence Imaging
knows that this is a pretty hard task to
do
um
especially if there are speed more
species than just a couple
but fortunately
more recently
we introduced a new uh microscopy
technique called Mass photometry
which is designed to do exactly that
task and since you're sitting in this
webinar you're probably familiar with
the technique but still I will go
through the basic principle very quickly
so you shine a laser onto a cover slip
which which holds the droplet of your
protein solution and um and then you
record the light that come that that
comes back
um onto a camera and uh the light that
comes back in this case is a combination
of the reflected light from the water
glass interface
and the scattered light from Little
objects that are sitting on that
interface and the reflected light
creates a bright background and wherever
a particle is sitting on the surface
um the scattered light will generate a
small inter destructive interference
and uh hence you will see kind of a dark
dip at that position and the Darkness of
that dip is directly proportional to the
size of your particle that you're
looking at
and you can calibrate that signal using
proteins of known size
and since every since all the proteins
have very similar Optical properties
you can basically
um get a mass distribution of your
proteins that land on the glass cover
slip
and I've done this for actin for example
and this is a a mass photometry video
that shows actin uh molecules landing on
a glass cover slip so every time you see
a dark dot that's a landing event and
the reason why they appear and
disappears just because we continuously
remove the static background so once the
particle has landed it becomes static on
the background and gets removed by the
image processing algorithm this way we
can
um we can image all the the proteins
that are coming in one after the other
and analyze their Darkness basically and
then
when you plot the darknesses or the
masses of all your molecules that you
have in your video in a histogram you
can generate
a size distribution of the protein and
and get an impression of what what type
of molecules and how many are in present
in solution
and this is very powerful because
um
the uh the mass resolution with mass
photometry is so high that we can
actually distinguish the different
oligomeric states as individual Mass
peaks in the size distribution
and now uh this uh this is also very
useful for the quantification of the
initial
um uh yeah polymerization reaction
since this is exactly what we needed uh
what I um talked about before
and you can also do that
um
you can also do that as a timed
experiment and the way the way I've done
it I um I I've taken a monomeric actin
solution added the polymerization status
let the polymerization incubate for a
while and after different time points
I pipeted some some sample out of that
out of that polymerizing solution into a
cover slip with a droplet of buffer and
um
uh and immediately watched Landing of
the molecules that have had formed after
these different time points
and if you then compare the mass
distributions
um of different acting concentrations at
different time points
you will see that if you're working at
or below the um the critical
concentration of filament formation
which is the red curve
there's not significant
um there's not a significant difference
um at the different time points but if
you work above the critical
concentration the equilibrium shifts to
larger molecular masses
and this can be a crucially Quantified
by taking the area under the curve of
this histogram and as you can see as I
said before like um beyond the critical
concentration you get growth essentially
and um below the critical concentration
the mass distribution stays more more or
less constant but this is really just a
very crude analysis the the actual
advantage of this lies in the fact that
we can quantify principally every
individual
um species that is present during the
polymerization process
um individually and take a Time course
of it
and the way I've done it
um I uh I I took the
um yeah the the size distribution and
use the combination of gaussian fitting
Plus for the well-defined Peaks and uh
just a simple binning for the less
well-defined Peaks for the higher masses
and um determined
um
molecule counts for each oligomous size
and this can since I know the overall
con concentration of actin can be
directly converted into concentrations
of of each of these species
and from from the gaussian fit
um I can I also know some parameters
from the experiment so in principle from
from any of these oligomous size
distributions and and counts I can
recreate based on the fit position of
the Peaks
as well as the width of the Peaks which
corresponds to the uh to the Mars noise
basically I can regenerate a mass this a
simulated Mass distribution
which I can directly compare with my um
with my experimental histogram
and this this is all I need to
essentially now test all the models that
are out there
um and compare them with my mouse
photometry measurements so I took the
set my common model
and simplified it a little bit by by
just breaking it down to the main
pathway because all the other pathways
are so unlikely that they don't really
contribute to the overall kinetics so
essentially I I took the
um
I took the the formation of the
longitudinal dime and then from there
um the uh yeah the pathway to the trima
tetrama and all the subsequent steps
and uh use the rate constants that are
provided in this paper
and then I needed to uh to solve a
couple of or derive a couple of
differential equations to describe this
equilibrium
basically in order to be able to create
um yeah time courses for the
concentration of each individual species
the only assumptions I made was I had to
limit the number of possible species to
an infinite a number which in my case
was 400.
um because otherwise I couldn't
um compute this and I had made the
assumption that every
um
that every step would just be by the
addition of a monomer and not bigger
species
and then
um one one last thing I needed was a
starting distribution uh for which I
took the um the experimentally
determined one at one minute
and then I let my simulation run and
from the concentration time course I
could pick the five minutes 10 minutes
and 15 minutes time point like I did in
my experiment
and re recreated for my from my time
from my concentration time course and
experimental histogram
that I could compare with my mass
photometry data and as you can see here
the sap McCammon model predicts overall
net growth over the course of the 15
minutes to Masters up to seven Mega Ball
but in the low mass regime it actually
predicts
um almost no abundance of diamonds and
trimus because they're incredibly
unstable according to their model but if
you um
if you remember my experimental data
there were actually quite significant
amounts of these small oligomers so the
um the simulated traces didn't match at
all my experimental Mass photometry data
I could I can do the same I can use the
same simulation to also produce
artificial bulk scattering curves which
I did and and compared it to an
experimental measurement and here I
actually
um kind of could recreate a like a very
similar curve
us which means that the set McCammon
model explains the data in the bulk but
it could not explain my mass photometry
data
my first attempt to
to uh yeah to to overcome this problem I
tried to adjust the rate constants of
the model until my experimental data and
uh and the size distribution perfectly
matched
but then I had the the issue that I
didn't observe any net growth uh into
long filaments as you can see in the in
the top uh time course of the
distributions and also uh there was the
light scattering curve was just a flat
line basically
huh this was this was a bit puzzling
because
um that that meant that the common model
could not explain
um at the same time my uh my bulk data
and the mass photometry data so I
stepped back and thought again about
what these nucleation models were
considering and I noticed that they
weren't really considering all the
information that is out there about
actin so first of all actin is a
um is a polar
polymer which means that one end is
different from the other end
um and the the different ends have
different
um uh Association and dissociation rate
constants this is something that these
models haven't considered so far and
also we know that actin is an atpase
which means
um usually ATP actin gets preferentially
Incorporated at the barbed end of the
filament and then once it's Incorporated
it can cleave ATP into ADP and phosphate
and then later on release the phosphate
and the ADP actin then preferentially
leaves the filament through the through
the pointed end
and the the common nucleation models
completely disregarded this effect so
far
so I I thought okay maybe I can modify
my model a little bit and
produce a simple model where I have one
equilibrium
where the the filament can grow from
both ends and then I notice that
um adppi actin has almost has a really
slowed down dissociation rate
at the pointed end which means that
essentially
um if if the the final subunit at the
pointed end at least it hydrolyzes its
ATP
um it will stop depolymerizing from that
end
um and uh so so essentially I I have a
slow transition
um
from from this top equilibrium to the
bottom equilibrium with different rate
constants when I plug this into my
simulation
I actually got very different curves out
and uh
in fact
um just using published rate constants
for the polymerization and
depolymerization rates from the barbed
and pointed ends
um already uh almost perfectly recreated
my experimental data in the low mass
regime plus I got net growth and could
actually
describe the this uh the bikes get
scattering curves much better than
before
and um to confirm I did I use the same
um kinetic rate constants and simulated
data for different actin concentrations
and in all the cases I could explain my
experimental data fairly well with with
this new model
so I think this this worked pretty well
but there was still a drawback and um
actually this came
especially during the review of the
paper in fact
um if if uh ATP hydrolysis is the actual
trigger of actin polymerization how come
that
um actin can still polymerize without
ATP hydrolysis for example you can
replace ATP with a non-hydrolyzable ATP
homolog amp p and p and you would still
get filaments and also you can
polymerize
actin just from ADP actin and there have
been papers that you can polymerize
actin
um with with no nucleotide at all so
okay how how can we explain this
um in fact actin can also bind
um usually for for polymerization actin
needs to bind divalent cations and in
order to keep it monomeric actin is
usually kept in a calcium solution
and then for um for polymerization you
exchange the calcium for magnesium and
calcium actin has different uh
polymerization rate constants then
magnesium actin
so in fact I tested what happens
um if I um do a mass photometry
experiment with amp p and p actin and
then use the rate constants for calcium
actin and magnesium actin and the
exchange rate
with the same kind of model on that data
and in fact I could explain the data
that I got out again very well and um I
even observed that ATP actin would give
me a lower amplitude in my bike
polymerization curves than the amp p and
p actin and the simulation with this
model could even explain the discrepancy
in the the amplitudes in these two
different experiments
um yeah so now finally you might ask
yourself
why
um do the
um the results in the bulk of the
nucleation models and these new
completely different models actually
look so similar well in fact this is
mostly because the the two principles
the kinetic principles are almost the
same in my opinion
for the nucleation model you have one
equilibrium
um with a less favorable
um uh with the less favorable
polymerization
um which uh which which is described by
a steeper Decay
um in the uh in the size distribution at
the beginning of the size distribution
and then
a slow transition to a second
equilibrium which with with much more
favorable
um growth rates
which can be explained by the by the
other half of the um and the the other
slope of the um of the size distribution
in the new model it's basically the same
you have one equilibrium which is
explained by the by the first half of
the um of the size distribution and the
higher slope in in the decay of the
species
and a slow transition to the second
equilibrium which is more favorable for
growth and I think
um
these uh this principle is is the reason
for um for the shape of these bulk
polymerization curves but of course on a
molecular level they work uh in a with
two completely different pathways
and um you can you can even uh and we
even identify two different Pathways for
actin one
um one was the calcium to magnesium
transition if you if you look at it uh
from a more far more Dynamic point of
view you can say the calcium state has a
less favorable
um Gibbs free energy of polymerization
and the Magnesium state has a more
favorable one and then in pathway two
um actin
um changes its uh yeah gives free energy
of polymerization to a more favorable
one by ATP hydrolysis
and in both cases you can generate net
elongation of actin filaments
well I do think that uh this doesn't
have to stop just ad acting
um in as I mentioned earlier there are
these um these amyloid fibrils which are
very important for the um
for the generation of different diseases
and in particular uh
nowadays it's uh it's thought that um
that the onset of these polymerization
reactions are the actual
cytotoxic events that uh that are
relevant for the uh for the progression
of the disease and therefore it since
since these systems lack the same
methodology for investigating the small
oligomers I think Mass photometry can
really help to gain more insights into
uh yeah into these disease mechanisms
finally I would like to thank a couple
of people especially
um my previous lab mates from the kukura
lab in Oxford they are an amazing group
of people and they are really good
microscope Builders
um without them it would have never been
possible to uh image and and do Mass
photometry on actin uh at this quality
I would also like to thank my
collaborators from Oxford who helped me
a lot in the data analysis and also
Josiah Kane from refine who helped me
with data analysis and our collaborators
from the NIH Jim Sellers and Harry
Takagi Who provided me with the raw
material for producing actin and finally
I would like to thank my new supervisor
Claudia Fieger here in Munich who gives
me the opportunity to explore
amazing new
avenues for applying mass photometry and
finally I would like to thank you for
your attention
thank you Nicholas for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
um just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so the first question that came up
Nicholas was what sophomore that you
software that used for analyzed
nucleation model and is that free
um yeah so I I produced the the analysis
software myself I mean for for producing
the mass distributions of course I just
used the normal refine software sorry I
need to go on that side
um I use the normal
refined software for creating the um the
mass distributions but um the um
the software for analyzing and
simulating the mass distributions I
created myself in in a python package
and it is freely available if you check
out the my publication in science
advances
um then you will find a link to a um to
a repository and I put all the codes on
there so you can download it if you like
great
and is time travel possible using Mass
spectrometry
um I don't think so
not yet
great
um and then we have a bit of a situation
here so someone said that they used MP
to study a Huntington fusion protein but
while the protein had a nominal mass of
58 KDA using the collaboration curve it
came out to be calculated as 74 KDA
which is significantly different than a
predicted five percent error can this
difference be attributed by the expanded
glutamines or something else that isn't
clear
[Music]
good question
from yeah from just this it's hard to
tell I must say
um
are you sure there was nothing else in
the sample I mean um if it I mean it
could be if there if there is a if you
co-purify a binding partner for the
Huntington fusion protein
maybe maybe it sticks to the protein or
something or maybe a chaperone or
something that uh because if of course
if you if you would detect the complex
that could explain
why you get a a mass increase
um I don't know if you like you can get
in touch with me maybe I can we can have
a look at the data together and uh and I
might help you resolve that issue
question
um excellent work Nicholas would you be
able to tell how well MP is compatible
with high 300 mm
NACI concentrations
oh yeah so that's not a problem actually
I've I've used even higher sodium
chloride concentrations the only
difference for higher salt concentration
is that the buffer then has a different
refractive index than at lower salt
concentrations so if you do your mouse
calibration you should always use the
same buffer and same salt concentration
as you use for your protein of interest
because yeah the the slope of the mass
calibration might be slightly different
at these high salt concentrations
great and how did Mass photometry help
you resolve biases with Kinetic model
overfitting
yeah so I think the
the main advantage of of mass photometry
for
um yeah for these polymerization
reactions is really that you can
quantify the the amount of small species
that are present during the
polymerization process and that way it's
it's a lot easier to find a molecular
pathway for the reaction than just using
bulk methods
awesome
Nicholas are there any drawbacks to
excuse me using mass photometry compared
to classical bulked based method methods
yeah
um
yes I I would say there is because
um I mean most
actin experiments so far have been done
at much higher concentrations as as you
might have noticed the concentration
that I've been working with were already
quite high from our photometry
um but I had to because the critical
concentration of actin is a 120
nanomolar and that's already fairly high
but in order to see something I had to
go higher than this
um and the way I overcome this problem
in my case was that I that I um put a
droplet of buffer onto my cover slip
beforehand and then I diluted my actin
solution into that droplet and hoped
that that the complexes that were
forming didn't fall apart during the
time of the acquisition
um that's that's how I had to do it in
this case so I think one of the major
drawbacks um for these kind of
polymerization reactions is really uh
that you that you might not get to the
concentrations that you need to for
polymer formation
great and it looks like we have one more
question
um if anyone has any more questions go
ahead and ask them now
um the next question for you Nicholas is
how does mass photometry compare to
other single molecule techniques for the
study of protein polymerization did you
consider using any of these other
techniques
um not in particular for the actin
polymerization I think
the the reason why there has never been
really as an experimental uh study
single molecule like single molecule
study on actin nucleation is because
it's super difficult with other
techniques for example
if you would be using something like a
single molecule fluorescence and do
something like step wise photo bleaching
and so on we would probably be able to
detect the
um the dimers and trimus that we've seen
with Mars photometry but it is much much
harder to quantify these and especially
um
especially for for for this huge number
of different species I think it's really
hard with especially fluorescence
techniques to get the same quality of
data that we got with Mass photometry
awesome
great well looks like that wraps up our
questions
um thank you Nicholas for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots in
our sponsor refine for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for or if something
else comes up
um in the on-demand period we will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it
is available for replay we do encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time thank you Nicholas and
goodbye
thank you goodbye